these are the same clothes I was wearing
two days ago
is there an agrees psychedelics in this
lion's mane that I'm drinking right now
[Music]
Julie's book is due tomorrow my book is
due tomorrow to podcast today and a
podcast on Friday and we just scheduled
another podcast for Saturday
damn Vietnamese coming over here and
then Monday is the plant-based nutrition
conference
[Music]
it ended up being not so bad yeah but
the weather conditions weren't we make
would be when your brain needs a hug
want to wear headphones I don't need to
yeah just make sure you're kind of like
let me hear how you sound check that's
good cool I'm sitting here with the
original fun guy himself to talk about
the magical mysterious medicinal
properties of the mycelium the mushroom
right yeah some guy I know we're gonna
unpack all of this it's really cool
thank you for coming up here thanks for
this uh thank you for bringing some of
your products we're drinking some lion's
mane tea yay maybe a good way to kind of
launch into it is just to establish or
at least kind of expand people's
awareness of this crazy Mushroom Kingdom
because we don't really think about much
we think about mushrooms in the context
of like mushrooms on our pizza and it
kind of ends there but you know
mushrooms are in 40% of pharmaceuticals
92% of plants are dependent on mushrooms
25% of the Earth's biomass is is is
mushroom based fungi based and I think I
read in your stuff like 85% of our RNA
and half of our DNA is shared with
mushrooms yeah
that's insane it is pretty Ennis we
don't even think about it's like this
invisible reality that surrounds us and
informs our world but it's not part of
our like daily consciousness or
awareness I mean I know you're working
to change that but that's the truth
right yeah so when does the idea you
know occur to you to create this
business out of mushrooms like what is
long from well yeah so at at one point I
was like eh I had seen is that like the
knowledge I learned growing up in
Finland was not commonly available like
I was one was just understanding is that
like a lot of people even a lot of like
successful people have no clue and a lot
of the kind of what I consider to be
somewhat basic knowledge and nutrition
and I saw them distressed levels and
just their life quality being pretty low
and so that was one thing the other
thing is that I you know I just I was me
personally was excited about it and I
was ordering like random capsules and
pills of various superfoods including
you know mushrooms from shady websites
as like trying to like put them in my
smoothies and and I thought this but
darkweb yeah this must be made easier
yeah yeah that was super fascinating I
mean I learned a ton there's still so
much to learn and very helpful you know
it's just it's it's enlightening and
illuminating to realize that there's
this whole world out there that that I
still have so much exploration you know
to go through and I think most people do
so thank you for the work that you do in
bringing this awareness to the world and
and helping people achieve better health
man it's cool and I'm excited for the
new book and the journey that you're on
and I'm here to support you every way I
can
bangs you've already done a lot and for
this episode you should do the mushroom
emoji and and peace oh yeah I will do
that yeah I'm fine instead of a piece
and then the plants I'll put a mushroom
yeah just one for one time yeah that's
good
yeah cool man all right man cool piece
and Russians awesome Terra was great I
think people are gonna really dig that
podcast I've known him for years and
years and years I think I first met him
like 2012
the very early stages of him creating
the company that is now for stigmatic I
thought I knew quite a bit about
mushrooms but over the course of an hour
and a half at arrow I realized there's
so much more to learn and his new book
healing mushrooms which is coming out
really soon which I've only begun to
start reading is fantastic it has
everything you need to take your
education about about how mushrooms can
aid and improve not only your health but
your athletic performance your mental
state your mental acuity your sleep
and even more beyond that so it was
really cool he was delightful and I
think
I was super engaging to share it when I
get a little bit rattled I write
reminders on my hand just so I don't
forget stuff and I wrote these wrote
these things in my hand and I'm looking
at it and I'm like I have no idea what
that am means like what is that what was
I trying to remind myself I couldn't
this whole drive down here I was trying
to think like what am I supposed to do I
just realized supposed to call Marco
dude how's it goin it was yeah it was it
was just it was larger than life it was
so much harder than I thought it was
gonna be and it just you know it just
delivered on its promise of being you
know a once in a lifetime you know
memory forever
cool man skit it's good to see you thank
you for making the time awesome thank
you for everyone yeah so you're on day
three of your hundred City day -
actually yeah I guess today with Seattle
and here we are in Los Angeles so stop
number two right and you're only here
for like a day right yeah pretty much
once the other day I think maybe we're
you know I come into the picture is I've
been writing about this kind of stuff
for about eight years I mean this is my
whole life I've done spine muscles I've
always worked for myself in one way or
another but I think what is shifting is
not just those things to think that's
been happening for a bit I think there's
a bit of a backlash to the idea that
everyone should be an entrepreneur
mm-hmm and that's partly where the side
estill thing comes in because I feel
like yes even though there's not great
job security etc there's a lot of people
who are actually kind of happy in their
jobs and I feel like they've been
largely ignored by the whole
entrepreneurial cults right every
business startup founder then you should
be ashamed of your exactly exactly like
I really do you perceive that people you
know feel bad and so a lot of the books
a lot of resources that are out there
kind of like hey quit your job you know
quit your job jump on the cliff
you know reinvent yourself fire your
boss etc and I'm partially guilty for
this you know because like I wrote a
book called hundred dollar startup which
have a subtitle like fire
I think I can pick this up title by the
way how the publisher did but still your
skill of Ithaca talking you virtual
thank you sir
yeah awesome so the new book is side
hustle you can find it wherever you
enjoy your literature Chris Gayle about
ZZ to find on the Internet at Chris
Killa I know I like how you're started
to do Instagram story I'm trying man
learning so much from you I child like
okay so I'm gonna be like no no it's
fantastic I've looked so much for you
yeah so if you want to check out Chris
he's get probably coming to a city near
you so you might be late to live in a
city right so where do they find the
schedule for where you're gonna be you
know it's actually going to be worldwide
its worst you know 40 cities or US and
Canada but then it's gonna go real wide
cytosol school calm / tour nice there
you go man
anything else you want to say no that's
a big honor thank you for conversation
and thank you for listening
yeah thank you thank you for having it
with me Chris alright now let's let's go
have fun with these people out here
right good all right
doing this earlier today the precise how
to get up and this year for like two
minutes before he sits up here and Lisa
I guess you could say my side muscle
became self a35 half that time I changed
my relationship with who achieve my
relationship to my physical body and I
changed my relationship with how I
relate to the world and in so doing I
experienced three remarkable changes
this golden spiritual and that got me
very interested in human potential so
this is just like a whole of the walk
with me up late
there's neighborhoods like all bars so
I'm getting loaded and all these bars
and this is where I've got him down
we drugs in alcohol how does it feel
like looking at me
like I mean I look at it like
nostalgically like I can't believe I've
changed so much but I also remember it
like it was yesterday like it seems like
a million years ago and it seems like
yesterday I know I still I'm very much
in touch with what that felt like and
where I was emotionally at that time
certain respects I was a completely
different person
but that's still Who I am you know and I
actually like it because I can it helps
me remember what I used to be like I
need to remember because if I forget and
then that's what begins the process of
leading backwards back towards that
so I kind of like coming back here
because it's even in like the air like
the way the air smells here like reminds
me of it
Oh
[Music]